welcome to the show hope everybody had a
good weekend I will talk a little bit
about mine on the bonus show today some
interesting things that went on the
vaccine chaos is growing dramatically
and we are already starting to see new
talking points develop from people who
simply don't want to talk about whether
they are vaccinated I will preview that
the term HIPAA plays a prominent role in
those talking points we also have an NFL
assistant coach who is out after
refusing a coveted vaccine and the NFL
clearly getting very very serious about
vaccination Rick Dennison is out as the
Minnesota Vikings assistant coach after
refusing a covid-19 vaccine after
refusing to receive a vaccine for
covid-19 Rick Dennison is out as the
Minnesota Vikings assistant coach
sources told ESPN Denison had served as
the Vikings offensive line coach Run
game coordinator the past two seasons in
a statement Friday the Vikings said they
were still in discussions with Denison
about the League's coveted protocols
another coach in the league New England
New England Patriots co-offensive line
coach Cole Popovich also won't be with
his team in 2021
in a decision related to the covid-19
vaccine and NFL guidelines League
sources confirmed to ESPN the vaccine is
required for all Tier 1 staff including
coaches front office Executives
equipment managers and Scouts players
are not required to receive the vaccine
but will face strict protocols during
training camp and throughout the season
that vaccinated players can forego I
will get to that in a moment in a memo
released by The League this summer the
NFL said any unvaccinated Tier 1 staff
member must provide a valid religious or
medical reason for not receiving the
vaccine losing Tier 1 status prohibits
coaches from being on the field and in
meeting rooms and having direct
interactions with players the Vikings
noted in their statement that Denison
does not have a vaccination exemption
the Vikings have promoted someone in
order to fill that seat so on and so
forth so a few different things uh to
think about here first and foremost is
this guy Denison going to eventually be
a republican Congress candidate for
Congress is he going to appear on Fox
News as a hero but even if he appears on
Fox News it would have to be via Skype
why well even though Fox hosts talk a
lot about vaccine requirements and
vaccine passports Fox requires that if
you don't want to wear a mask in their
facilities that you have to be wearing a
you have to be wearing a mask so I guess
this guy could be hailed as a hero on
Fox news but would have to do the
interview via Skype because he's not
vaccinated so that hypocrisy is just
incredible now as I tweeted about this
when the news broke the team as a
private business made a decision about
how they wanted to employ people without
breaking any law the coach made a
decision about where he would or would
not like to work this is in effect the
libertarian Paradise this is happening
by the way around the same time that the
NFL has had to postpone games because of
coronavirus outbreaks among unvaccinated
players or staffers and that those are
not going to be rescheduled if indeed
that would have I think I was not clear
they announced that they will not be
rescheduling games that happen as a
result of that are postponed as a result
of unvaccinated people if people are
unvaccinated and there's an outbreak
that's going to just be a forfeit and
the NFL getting very very strict about
this stuff they also announced that they
are going to be finding unvaccinated
players fourteen thousand dollars if
they violate coveted protocols and the
new Protocols are quite quite
interesting the NFL having one list of
protocols if you're fully vaccinated and
another if you're not so for example if
you're fully vaccinated you don't need
to be tested daily if you're not
vaccinated you will need to be tested
every single day if you're fully
vaccinated you don't need to wear a mask
when you were at the team's facility or
during travel if you choose not to be
vaccinated you will be required to wear
a mask All Season presumably at Club
facilities and during travel
um other uh examples there will be no
physical distancing required if you are
with other vaccinated individuals and
are vaccinated yourself versus if you
are not fully vaccinated you have to
remain physically distant presumably for
the entire season so I don't know about
you but if I was a player
um I would be wanting to be fully
vaccinated in order not to have to do
any of that stuff and there are already
people who are typically on the oh the
NFL is so fantastic and it's patriotic
and all of this stuff who are saying
screw football if they want to go woke
by the way following the science is not
wokeness it's just following the science
if they want to go all whatever it is
that the right claims they are going
then I'm not going to watch the NFL is
the one that's coming up now and you
know what that is all the marketplace of
ideas the NFL broke no laws by putting
these rules in place if they lose
business or viewership or whatever as a
result that was their choice to make if
people don't want to work for the NFL or
for any particular team because of the
rules they are free to go and Market
their labor elsewhere and if the
audience doesn't want to watch the NFL
in protest of these rules they are free
to do that and then that will have an
impact and the NFL will have to decide
whether it's worth it or not it seems to
me
based on everything that's going on
including with the Delta variant
Etc that the NFL is simply being
cautious because they want to preserve
the Integrity of their season and people
can disagree and then they can vote with
their eyeballs and choose to watch
something else